hi everyone and high cameras i am a matt
welch editor-in-chief of Reason magazine
welcome to our little hovel here in Los
Angeles we're here to talk about video
game nation which is an awesome issue of
the magazine that's fresh out on stands
here I hope that y'all go to our special
landing page where I think you can
actually even play a game although I
understand so little about video games
that I'm not sure if that's actually
true I'm here with a Tracy falutin who's
a game designer and academic and craig
allen who is a CEO of a game company
we're going to talk about how video game
market has changed american life and
where it's going and we're going to take
some questions and we're going to have a
good time I want to start this whole
thing off though by getting a sense of
the room how many of the 40s three
people in this room play video games
let's say once a week okay so around
half a little bit less how many once a
month at least that includes the once a
week people come on how many you're
unfamiliar with mathematics yeah and how
many people are like my dad and think
that we're talking about game shows
tonight that's awesome so I'm in that
latter group which made it particularly
fun and rewarding for me to edit this
issue of reason because we have a lot of
people on staff including Scott
shackford Scott are you in this room
right now there he is I want to give
special credit for Scott for this issue
Scott probably has played as many video
games today as I have in the last 20
years and he really helped throw the
cover story a profile on representative
Jared Paulus who's really the first kind
of video game congressman and a very
interesting libertarian Democrat at a
Colorado and a lot of Scott's thinking
went into this issue so I just want to
acknowledge the great man but we so part
of my interest in this whole concept was
hey I don't know this stuff that's going
on and is and is transforming American
culture and I learned all kinds of crazy
things
in the process of during this issue such
as video game companies employee
economists to study how people interact
with one another and how they deal with
currencies and these economists will
tell you this is the best economics that
we can do forget macroeconomics we can
actually measure everything here and we
can and it's exposing that real world
economics doesn't really work we found
recent polling here Emily Ekins is
hopefully in the room as well she did
some special polling on this looking at
the attitudes of people who play games
frequently and they turn out to be to
have much more broad sense of tolerance
of wanting thinking that individual
freedom is a core value all kinds of
issues like that that came to the
forefront when learning this so i will
stop blathering but i just want to for
all of you to people who are like my
father and myself and don't understand
video games at all hopefully we will
leave you with a sense that pretty
interesting topic is changing culture
it's changing politics even and it's
certainly changing business so I'm
starting the craig allen here who is the
CEO of spark unlimited not sparks
unlimited i keep going to the to the
rock band here spark a limited is famous
for call of duty finest hour and also
turning point fall of liberty which
hopefully will talk about a little bit
Craig I wanted you to just sort of give
us a sense from us dumb outsiders how
big is the video game industry
comparators other things that we
intuitively have a sense of like say the
movie industry what is the size and
scope of this thing now it's big really
really big that helps those math people
that we were talking to earlier so
that's the basic piece of the equation
actually the game industry is really
exciting because when I started back in
the early 90s and you know when the
arcades were around in the 80s it was
much more about an enthusiast it was
somewhat social but kind of a niche
market and in the living room there's
only kind of so many people you can
reach and in a computer or PC there's so
many people who can reach but now
everybody has a computer in their pocket
we're walking around with these mobile
devices we're about to start having
wearable technology and as technology
becomes ubiquitous and we have
connections
games are just a natural outgrowth of an
ability to socialize so I think that as
much as I like to look at video games as
a category and we're on our way to being
depending on what numbers you want to
use a hundred billion dollar industry or
what you know it's it's big I think that
thinking about video games as a game
actually limits what we're really doing
in terms of our impact on the world
right now because games are things that
are just about having social currency so
you can talk about a game as
entertainment but you can also talk
about something that's a construct for
how you live your life whether that's
being better at fitness programs whether
that's having a linkedin profile that
has a status bar that shows you how
complete your profile is so it's game is
how we gamma phi our lives in addition
to well actually playing how we quantify
our lives right games are about
statistics games are about data games
are about understanding relative value
in terms of your performance so as we
start to be able to track everything you
know it's the game of life this is a
good segue into Tracy Tracy is not only
a game designer which we're going to
talk about a little bit but she also
runs the Annenberg School of what is
actually the USC school cinema
television has a interactive median
games division yes it is very long yes
so and I'm the chair of the interactive
median games I mean first of all like
you're an academic or studies video
games do half of your colleagues just
roll their eyes at you when you walk
down saying this is a legitimate
academic discipline well so I actually
come I came to academia from the game
industry so I'm sort of a transplant and
about 10 years ago when we started the
program that that was exactly the case
is that people kind of go we teach what
and you know as we became more
established and we had a lot of success
stories coming out of the program a lot
of entrepreneurial students starting on
companies one of the companies it has
come out in the past 10 years one game
of the year last year and multiple
honors have gone to a number of other
games so you start to see students
coming out of the program
who are innovative they're you know
they're they're savvy their creative
they're able to put businesses together
and make kind of amazing you know
product that's getting out there and and
changing the way that people think about
not only what games are but how they're
made let's talk about what what are we
doing when we play games besides
obviously you know punching prostitutes
and stealing people's cars what are what
are people actually engaging in and
doing when they're playing games yeah so
I mean you know the thing about games is
that they're pretend right okay first
the first thing is is that other than
this this this quantification they also
are there a safe place where we can
practice things and we can rehearse
ideas we can say do I want to punch the
Ponce prostitute what would happen if I
punch the prostitute right and we sort
of tests those boundaries like we did
when we were a kid right I mean that is
you know in many ways where the play
instinct evolved as a part of learning
right and and humans play when they're
young and you know we not so much when
we get older but what's interesting is
as we we have to continue evolving now
in this society where technologies and
changing and our we're happy more
adaptable longer into life play has
become more important to us longer into
our lives i think so i think that play
instinct is the core of what we're
engaging in we're learning to test
boundaries we're learning to create
constructs in our mind about what's
going to happen if and then we'll go out
and practice those things master them
now is this replacing maybe we're not
doing the same thing in the playground
that we used to we're not punching as
many prostitutes as we used to in the
playground or is this is this replacing
behaviors and and even kind of creating
a safer place for certain types of
experimentation than we had 20 years ago
I think it's extending those behaviors
and I think that they're still always
going to be a place for one-on-one in
person you know we you know humans love
to be together and to like physically
and interact it's actually one of the
reasons you're seeing games extending
out of the the computer into real life a
little bit like what Craig is saying
about quantifying your life and being
able to play in social networks so yeah
it's great to take perhaps unsafe
behaviors things like and maybe not
great behaviors like punching
prostitutes and put them on the screen
but then it's also great to extend back
into real life and say hey I can I can
walk more steps than you today let's see
right and and bring those behaviors back
into our social networks Craig how do
you you're going to follow up go ahead I
was just going to say I think that's
really the core of it which is games are
about giving you a place that's safe to
play in so much in our life we don't
touch this don't do that don't go there
don't do that it's all about the don'ts
and you go into a game environment and
you can experiment you can you can try
things out you can try a different
persona you can try a different style of
play yes there's maybe a construct
within the game that incentivizes you to
do certain things for the best results
but that freedom allows you to discover
and I think that that you're starting to
see some interesting data from
researchers saying that even violent
video games actually decrease the
aggression and hostility of the players
because it's cathartic it's a way of
releasing tension because they get to
kind of you know play out these things
that they wouldn't do in real life when
you do it yeah now obviously there's
always going to be outliers that have a
hard time separating real from fantasy
and whether it's a movie or a book or a
comic book or a game there's it becomes
a dumping ground for this is this is
creating issues there are people that
just have issues but for the bell curve
the middle of it it actually i think is
really positive and we're seeing crime
rates come down and a lot of things that
some people are drawing corollaries to
people being able to act out in a in a
safe way irresponsible behavior there's
a great piece in here by Jesse Walker
about kind of a history of moral panics
about games that people play whether
it's poker it's picked in New York City
they were smashing pinball machines with
sledgehammers in the 70s there's so many
things that smashed in New York in the
1930s pin militia in the 1970s that all
had a kind of all came from gambling it
became a skill-based game to avoid
legislation because it was a gambling
system bumpers and then they added the
flippers so that they could get her
round sir
gambling let's see I did not know
flipper history here talk a little bit
about the way that the industry is
organized right now is it a blockbuster
industry the same way that Hollywood has
become a blockbuster industry how does
what constitutes this 100 billion dollar
or whatever it is buying you know I
think I think it's a our industry like
many media industries like many
businesses today I think are becoming
incredibly stratified between the
blockbusters the big margin the high
quality experience that people will pay
for and walmart or you know free to play
or reality TV tell my dad what
free-to-play is ok so free to play like
I use my dad as it's his fault not mine
but I don't understand what for you two
players so basically we used to have
kind of a one-size-fits-all pricing in
the industry so you'd go to walmart you
buy a forty-dollar game or a 50 lr game
you'd take it home you'd play it and
that was the transaction now that we
have digital delivery now that you have
mobile apps you have more accessibility
to content people are trying different
pricing models everything from you pay
for the app for like 3 99 or a dollar 99
to take it for free but if you want to
get other levels or you want to have
other characters or you want other
elements or features you pay
incrementally so it's free to play to a
point of monetization and it's another
area where the game industry like like
television and many industries are
finding new parameters to reach the
audience in a way that they feel
comfortable so you have you no pay and
no ads you have free and adds you have
subscription-based limited access
pay-per-view all these different formats
are pricing are now coming into the game
industry and it's a big change because
we didn't used to have that you know we
had online kind of advergames type
things but we're now seeing all new
models come out which are pretty excited
and you have entire parallel universe
filled with hundreds of thousands
sometimes millions of people who are
starting businesses in that universe
your skin
me with all this stuff no tell me tell
me what the hell is going on over there
well basically we're playing a game
within the game right because this is
all a simulation okay this you aren't
really in this room because we all saw
the matrix right we know that this isn't
real no but but that's but that's
essentially what we're doing right is
where we're moving further and further
into immersive reality and if you see
things like oculus rift or these other
technologies like the Google glass is a
first step you're going to be able to go
further and further into a believable
recreation of of a reality and and I
think the bigger question is you know
what happens when that reality is more
compelling than the one we live in we're
already starting to see some some early
edge cases of people not eating starving
themselves dying at a computer terminal
because they're so immersed in the the
the fantasy that they don't want to
leave and you know whether it's a game
or whether it's just work look at work
patterns right you used to have a job at
an office and you would leave now you
take your work with you and there's this
social pressure like I sent you a text
message why didn't you respond to spend
three minutes because I'm don't live
with my technology all the time but the
expectation grows so at what point do
you stop having control over your own
life because the demands of your virtual
life take over the way that you smile
when you say that really sends a chill
down my spine now your world that you're
creating is obviously Walden Pond and
Henry David Thoreau talk a little bit
about what you're doing well you know
it's interesting that you bring this up
because I think that one of my reasons
for beginning this project was to find a
kind of balance right for my for myself
um and to explore how you might create a
game that would not be so compulsive to
play would be a beautiful and
interesting and compelling experience
but one that would actually point you
back towards a better sense of balance
between what you know you must do to
survive
and what you might do to sort of make
your life better and and I so this is a
game where basically you play out the
experiment that the thorough set for
himself at Walden Pond to live this
simple basic existence and kind of bring
down his his his life to its bare
essence so you he lays out what hit he
thinks are the sort of you know bear
components of life to survive and in
this this climate as he says and that's
food fuel shelter and clothing and
that's so the basis of our simulation
you could actually probably find more
modern models of what per person needs
to survive but we decided to go with
what the RO had laid out and so you have
to care take these basic needs on the
other hand if you just care take them
your life will be somewhat dismal in
this this rich of world that we've built
if you are able to balance between the
basic needs and the sort of you know
these more ephemeral needs a discovery
around the pond and interacting with
nature and doing some of the really
interesting scientific casts that he set
for himself for example on then you will
you'll achieve this balance and the
world itself responds to that balance
and becomes a richer experience for you
how do you create this stuff I mean that
sounds phenomenal to me but how do you
create it at the kind of granular level
of the universe of you know it's a great
question actually and and and I think
that you know when you're talking about
for example getting into a world of full
immersion it's important to recognize
that every game is an abstraction and it
is a simulation and as simulations are
that you choose what it is you're
simulate it is not actually the real
world it we've made very specific
choices there are like you know just
over 200 animal species and plant
species in the world and those were
chosen by going through the text of
Walden and seeing we actually you know
did a coating of it seeing which one's
the row mentions the most which ones he
finds the most interesting which he if
he describes them at great length and so
it isn't a objective look at
say Walden today or even Walden of the
time it is a translation into a playful
form of what he wrote in his book
although I think it's really interesting
is for me the game designer is a
behavioral modification engineer right
because what they're really doing is
incentivizing you to run down a certain
path and seek a reward that they want
you to seek you might have lots of
choice you might not have any choice but
they try to design it so that you seek
out the situation and the results
without you even really knowing it
intuitively to discover what they want
you to learn so when you're talking
about what you're teaching you you
created this beautiful world but but
actually what they're trying to teach
you is live a better life yes outside of
this world but but but by understanding
by coming to the conclusion that you
have to achieve this balance in world
I'm hoping for some sort of transference
to the real world but I would imagine
also there might be a tension among
players they want more and more control
over their future including their
choices right and they want to be able
to create their own sets of architecture
not just deal with your paternalistic
choice architecture mr. and so do you
get punished if you actually know in
fact you know in in this game by just in
this particular game we actually talk
about that so you can become what we
call a wall to millionaire which a condo
and a big skyscraper you basically can
grow your bean field and sale sell that
you can take odd jobs and you can buy
find a fancy suit and you can upgrade
your little house and you can become a
Walden millionaire but you will never
have this rich experience that I'm
talking about you will have all those
other things right and that is that as a
way of winning right but you will never
find you know all there they're all
these jewels of experiences that are in
the world that you won't actually find
but but that's where I go back to a game
is a construct of rules for a purpose
that you incentivize people to
accomplish right so when we talk about a
game as a simulation you can think of
that as like a video game like simple
simplistic like space invaders or
asteroids or you know cause effect life
death action reaction but it's also more
broadly it's it's the rules that we live
our lives by right
it's the construct of if you have a job
and you want to get a promotion and you
want to get a raise and you want to get
a house and you want to have a family
and you want to send to a good school
how do you get into University that's
become a whole game the University game
is it is dazzling and it's not very well
designed we actually made a game at one
of the other games that I'm working on
is a game about how to get into
University because it is a game right
and so and there's so many kids out
there who come from families at you know
or are in schools where the counselors
are disappearing like you know crazy at
this point and so we said well hey let's
make a game that teach them how to play
this game since you only get to play
this game once right would it be neat if
you could rehearse that and learn how to
play this game I like that one of your
games sort of set people back to just
before World War two is kind of a
revisionist history or choices that you
can have there is there something
inherent two games kind of in the way
that I think there's something inherent
to science fiction that makes you think
kind of big picture this is how the
world works or doesn't work kind of
questions and therefore this is a
largely for this audience out here I
forces people to ask essentially
libertarian questions like what is the
role of this state what is the role of
you know the use of force in these types
of things is there something inherent to
the video game world I think that for
our for the game industry we started out
as a very kind of diverse really wide
creative spectrum industry with arcades
and and lots of experimentation and when
we kind of went through this home
console push and a push to high prices
retail oriented package media things
became kind of collected around
blockbuster entertainment so I think the
kind of games that you're seeing a lot
of are the ones that much like Hollywood
work for a wide audience are things that
work really well on a poster they get
people interested angry emotionally
reacting to the topic in a way that gets
them invested and a lot of those I think
become socially relevant because it's
what we're dealing with right so for us
with with turning point versus
callofduty call a duty for us
was at the time our team have been
working on medal of honor and doing a
lot of things about finding honor and
glory in World War 2 is kind of the
greatest generation and these themes of
what do you fight for as a soldier call
of duty was about as contrast was the
one we did a bunch of different soldiers
from different nationalities basically
following orders trying to find out
where is that line between personal
responsibility obligation and duty to
country because you may not want to do
what you're doing but you have a duty to
serve and then with turning point it was
looking at a flip on the soldier and
saying but what happens when the war
comes to you as an American in New York
what if there was this alternate
timeline and d-day basically happened
here a citizen's choices are very
different than a soldier's choices they
don't necessarily follow the same logic
or the same path and they have to find
their own reasons to what they fight for
and why they fight and propaganda
becomes a big thing so for me you know
there was a lot of themes that were
coming out of 9 11 and and what was
happening in our country in terms of you
know where do we draw that line between
safety and personal freedom where do we
think about as a citizen what our role
is to to temper and and work with or
work against our government and so
anyway I think that that in the kind of
big game oriented products whether you
look at current call of duty you know
you're finding these reflections of the
times we're living in because they have
the broadest appeal but what's exciting
on a creative level is what's happening
now in the in the emerging markets with
mobile tablet digital we're back to a
really creative verse diverse spectrum
so you're finding lots of little games
that can explore really really small
topics like you know I want to play as a
plague which is you know a great little
app on the App Store where you play a
virus and try to kill all life on Earth
not something that would necessarily be
sold at Walmart but but it's a great
little game right I mean you feel really
bad when humans survive like
but you know whether it's a tour like
there's a game that Monument Valley
which takes MC escher prints basically
as inspiration and plays with
perspective and allows you to try to
solve puzzles by making impossible
situations so I think it's a really
exciting time for games and whether it's
for entertainment or like we're talking
about with real-world applications a
friend of mine has a leaf and and they
took it into the dealership to be
serviced and they came back and said hey
congratulations and she's like what well
you're the most fuel-efficient driver in
California yeah because if you keep the
leaf in the little bars it's like that's
maximum fuel efficiency and so now she
wants to be the best fuel efficient
driver in the US right she's like
religiously driving that car it became a
game right it's a car but now it has
data and feedback that allows you to
improve performance and I think the
silver lining in the hope for the world
is we generally want to be better and if
we can give people better feedback and
better data and better access to each
other to coach mentor and courage we can
make a better world I want to thank you
both Tracy cold and creating incredible
learning process here tonight so give
them around
I'll just sign up for the purposes of
reason TV for reason TV i am at welch
and goodnight and God speed and go drink
have fun while we're